wir verzichten den biogarten ja auch
meine ridinger und deswegen ist es
gerade bei uns im garten sind wichtig
dass wir auf einen gesunden und
fruchtbaren wonach die und da sind
bodenlebewesen super elementar und wehrt
sich mit bodenlebewesen richtig gut
auskennt und lucky aus meinem team
sie hat nämlich ökologische
landwirtschaft studiert und sich während
ihres studiums ganz intensiv mit dem
thema boden beschäftigt und auch mit dem
thema bodenleben und freut sich total
ist hier sind ganz ganz ganz viel weiß
und uns ganz viel erzählen kann und uns
dabei helfen kann
unsere boden legen macht also ich jetzt
nicht willkommen danke david ist schön
dass ihr so viel los topf auf mehr über
bodenlebewesen zu erfahren dann kam ja
ganz viele kommenden tage auch dass er
richtig bock drauf hat und deswegen
finde ich hier und ich freue mich dass
ich mich eingeladen hat ich mag es ja
mal für alle die noch nicht so boden
nötig sind und nicht so wurden
begeistert mal erzählen was am boden
denn so wichtigen und so faszinierend
ist also für mich ist der boden nicht
einfach nur ein bisschen dreck oder ein
bisschen staub sondern der boden ist ein
ziemlich ausgeklügeltes system das kann
man sich so ein bisschen wie ein schwamm
vorstellen habe ich mitgebracht wurden
fügen sich lose mineral teilchen
beschloss partikel oder ton partikel zu
größeren aggregaten zusammen und dadurch
entsteht im boden einen pool system
wodurch der boden belüftet wird und
wodurch wasser in den boden eindringen
kann und in dem boden raum wohnen auch
richtig viele bodenlebewesen und genau
und so soll es ja heute geben ich find
die bodenlebewesen auch gerade deswegen
so spannend weil sie an unglaublich
wichtigen prozessen beteiligt sind
wenn man sich mal vorstellen dass man
einfach bioabfälle und ernte reste und
alles mögliche auf dem kompost wirft und
dann noch andere sachen auch ja und da
ist doch total faszinierend dass du so
viel zeug zusammen wirfst und dann am
ende so eine schwarze krümel ege scheine
dürften der erde ernte ist und wenn die
wunde gewesen nicht werden die da
einziehen und ihr werk verrichten
wer das als die können ja noch viel mehr
als organischer substanz zu zersetzen
die bauern humus auf die mineralisierten
er stoffe oder sie fix hier nährstoffe
und generell sich die am gesamten
stickstoffkreislauf und am kohlenstoff
kreislauf beteiligt das sind mitunter
die prozesse die dazu führen dass
in unserem biogarten das gemüse so gut
wächst und gedeiht deswegen einen tusch
auf die bodenlebewesen bei denen wir uns
heute ein bisschen näher beschäftigen
wollen wenn es auf jeden fall total
spannend wenn du uns meine
vogelperspektive geben würdest auf das
bodenleben wer das überhaupt ist und da
sind ja auch ganz spannende
faszinierende kandidaten dabei und sonst
da einfach mal so einen kleinen
rundumschlag geben würde ist ja nicht
die bodenlebewesen sind super vielfältig
und es gibt auch richtig viele
spezialisten unter den lebewesen später
würde ich euch auch wohl gerne noch zwei
kandidaten vorstellen aber genau ich
denke auch am anfang ist eine
vogelperspektive ganz spannend und man
kann die bodenlebewesen ganz gut ihrer
größe nach einteilen da gibt es zum
einen die riesen unter dem
bodenlebewesen das sind zum beispiel
maulwürfe oder mäuse und das sind
meistens auch die kandidaten die nicht
so gerne gesehen werden im garten weil
sie sich eben nicht an gerade aussaat
rillen halten und mitunter ganz schön
viel chaos im gemüsebeet anrichten
können aber die haben auch ihre
berechtigung dann gibt es die normalos
regenwürmer ganz viele käfer oder auch
schnecken oder hassen die gehören zu den
normalos da gibts noch nicht zu
verkleinern
und dann kommen die gerade so noch als
gross bezeichnet werden genau
und dazu gehören die endlich tränen das
sind die kleinen verwandten von den
regenwürmern oder auch die milben oder
die springschwänze die hallen
unglaublich wichtige aufgaben im boden
die fressen nämlich die organische
substanz also die ente reste oder auch
das laub oben auf dem boden und
durchwühlen das in den mineral boden
dadurch dass die organische substanz in
dem mineral boden eingemischt wird
gelangen auch humus in die tieferen
bodenschichten und dadurch wird der
wurzelraum für die pflanzen verbessert
und die pflanzen können ihre wurzeln
viel einfacher in tiefere bodenschichten
strecken und das ist ziemlich cool
das ganze nennt man auch biotop aktion
also die bodenlebewesen haben da zwei
ganz wichtige große aufgaben einmal die
sachen zerkleinern die so anfallen
genommen und dann sie im boden zu
verteilen und eine ganz besondere rolle
nimmt der regenwurm ein denn der
vermischt in seinem darm organische
partikel mit mineral teilchen und
dadurch entstehen super super
fruchtbaren humus komplexe und in einen
fruchtbaren boden können sie sogar noch
weiter
so darf am ende richtig coole krümmel
entstehen und ich weiß nicht wie es dir
geht aber wenn ich so einen krümeligen
boden in der hand
dann geht es noch nicht
dann kommen die mikroorganismen also die
ihr mann definitiv nicht mehr als groß
bezeichnen kann und dazu gehören zum
beispiel die bakterien und pilze das und
glaube dass die bekanntesten vertreter
algen und nematoden fadenwürmer gefunden
auch zu die sollte man nicht
unterschätzen obwohl sie so klein sind
weil die einen gesamtanteil an der
biomasse im boden ausmachen von 90
prozent also das ist der löwenanteil und
ist damit ab und damit auch die
pflanzenwurzeln main mit der biomasse
oder nur wie das bodenleben dass die
biomasse bezeichnet in dem fall nur das
boden leer aber es trotzdem enorm denkt
man gar nicht mehr weil man die jedem
nicht so präsent vor augen hat ja die
arbeiten die ganze zeit undercover und
übernehmen aber richtig richtig wichtige
aufgaben und gerade weil man sie nicht
sieht finde ich sie auch noch mal fast
ein bisschen faszinierender als die
größeren bodentiere von denen beiden
möchte ich euch auch gerne noch zwei
kandidaten vorstellen
ja dann hat das rein ja wir würden
anfangen mit der muko rinser kannst du
dir da di meco ried sei es eine
lebensgemeinschaft zwischen pilz und
pflanzen wurzeln sagt sogar dass die
besiedlung von pflanzen auf der
erdoberfläche überhaupt erst
stattgefunden haben kann durch diese
miko rita das heißt die politischen
richtig dass er auch früher war ja auch
beide davon profitieren also sowohl die
pflanze als auch der kirche pilz bekommt
von der pflanze kohlenhydrate das für
produkte aus der photosynthese die
pflanze bekommen von dem pilz wasser
oder stickstoff aber vor allem auch
phosphor und das ist super wichtig weil
phosphor ist im boden nicht so gut
mobilisierbar ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch
damit schon mal beschäftigt habt aber
die phosphor vorkommen sind endlich dass
es gibt auch den begriff pick phosphor
hatten einigen jahren werden wir
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so einfach
rausgehen können und unsere pflanzen mit
phosphor düngern und deswegen wird die
mikro rita in zukunft immer wichtiger
werden vor allem wenn man in einem bio
garten gärtner hat wo man
ähnlich mit so vielen bürgern arbeiten
möchte haben wie ist das sind alle nico
rita kitze gleich oder gibt es auch ganz
viele unterschiedliche es gibt
unterschiedliche arten von mitrovica
pizzen die die bei uns im garten
eigentlich am wichtigsten sind sind die
mit dem komplizierten namen abos cholera
miko rietavas richtig bäumchen förmige
wurzeln liegen an der schnittstelle mit
der pflanze bäumchen artige strukturen
aus und daher kommt der name und an
dieser schnittstelle findet dann auch
der stoffaustausch zwischen pflanze und
dem pilz statt maximal zählen wie du das
machst mit ihrem garten oder was zu
einem raten würdest soll man nie polizei
gezielt im garten ansiedeln oder denkst
du das braucht es nicht die sind sowieso
schon da
du kannst schon einiges tun um deine mit
kubica im boden zu fördern
zum einen indem du regelmäßig einfach
pflanzenanbau ist in den beeten die
ebenso mikrorisse ausbilden können dazu
gehören liege minuten also zum beispiel
erbsen oder bohnen aber auch mais
kartoffeln topinambur ans viele tolle
gewesen die eine gruppe die genau eine
kuh kann es leider nicht und zwar die
kohl gewechselt werden keine micky maus
auch ein grund eine gute fruchtfolge
einzuhalten das sage ich ja immer wieder
gerade bei kohlgemüse echt eine weitere
fruchtfolge einhalten und das kommt dem
ihr auch entgegen wenn man ständig
hintereinander kohl auf einem beet
anbaut
dann ist es nicht gut für die koreaner
wenn man eine weite fruchtfolge lässt
und dazwischen immer wieder pflanzen
anbaut wie mit denen besser können dann
fördert man die eben auch ohne cory zwar
werden auch nicht so gerne mist gedüngt
also die pilze sondern du kannst etwas
gutes tun wenn du eher kompost in deinen
beten aus bringst und dafür bietet ja
perfekt zu marie kartensystem da wird ja
auch ganz junge kompost gearbeitet es
gibt in der forschung unterschiedliche
meinungen wie es mit einer boden störung
aussieht ich habe schon paper gelesen da
wurde davon berichtet dass wenn du
deinen boden umgräbt nico rita pilze
sogar gefördert werden aber andere
forschungsergebnisse sagen auch dass man
den boden möglichst schlicht hören soll
weil dann die pitts fäden im boden nicht
gestört werden und
würde ich ihn ärgern genau 100 jahren
genau so ein bisschen kann ist denke ich
auch ganz cool weil so kannst du so ein
paar kleine pizzen vielleicht stören so
dass der pilz angeregt wird wieder neuer
auszubilden aber du hast nicht einmal
den ganzen garten boden um und verstößt
das ganze pilzgeflecht im boden also
alle die sie noch nicht kennen wir
arbeiten ja ganz viel mit der grabegabel
genauer gesagt mit der doppel grabegabel
also einer großen mit der man auch
großflächig ziemlich viel im garten
ziemlich schnell und einfach bearbeiten
kann das kommt eben auch voll entgegen
so wie wir das einschätzen wie du das
thema impfen findest du sind wahr oder
nicht in den boden mit mikros sein also
ich hab das mal in der popkultur gemacht
weil ich es einfach mal ausprobieren
wollte ich meine auch dass die pflanze
sich entwickelt hat
mit der mit kubica im kultur das ist
jetzt nicht wissenschaftlich gesichert
weil dann hätte ich das viel häufiger
ausprobieren müssen in den meisten böden
sind sowieso miko rita pilze enthalten
und deswegen bin ich der meinung dass
man sich eine impfung eigentlich auch
sparen kann solange man darauf achtet
sein boden so zu bearbeiten dass der
pilz halt auch gute chancen hat könnt
euch gerne mal das video da oben
anschauen da geht es ja um boden
schonende bodenbearbeitung also wie man
ohne umgraben gärtnern kann ich hätte ja
mal erzählen wir das so handhabt mit den
fugen zeigen wie man die messe und die
mit kurzen das hier könnt ihr gerne
erzählen wenn es da einige von euch gibt
die sich vielleicht mit dem thema auch
schon beschäftigt haben dann bin ich
ganz gespannt was der zweite kandidat
ist sofort stellen recht ist als
nächstes über die gleichen bakterien
erzählen oder auch libyen genannt das
ist auch eine symbiose und zwar gehen
die kirche materien eine symbiose mit
den dosen ein also mit erbsen bohnen
sojabohnen das kult ist dass die
stickstoff aus der luft fixieren und im
boden in eine form umwandeln die für die
pflanzen wieder verfügbar ist in der
luft ist nämlich unglaublich viel
stickstoff vorhanden das ist total cool
wenn man den nutzen kann als dünger für
seine pflanzen und das kennen wir und es
ist total faszinierend ja und auch hier
haben wieder beide parteien was von der
symbiose also die pflanze wird von den
kirchen bakterien mit
stickstoffverbindungen versorgt und die
ganze wiederum gibt den
gleichen bakterien kohlenhydrate damit
die zocker genau die sind hungrig und
können dadurch ihr hohes energielevel
aufrechterhalten die beiden parteien
arbeiten auch richtig eng zusammen
das kann man auch ganz gut beobachten
wenn ihr mal eine erbse oder einem boden
pflanze aus ihrem garten ausgraben und
die wurzeln anschaut dann seht ihr da
ganz oft solche knüppel an den wurzeln
und dass er heißt eben dass diese
symbiose da zustande gekommen ist da
kann man auch sehen wenn es mal nicht
geklappt hat kann man sich überlegen was
dann schief gelaufen sein jacket was
könnte das denn für gründe geben wenn
sich das mal nicht bildet an den wurzeln
das könnte sein dass du dein boden
sowieso mit super viel stickstoff
gesorgt da denken die pflanzen jo was
sollen wir noch diese symbiose ein wäre
ganz sogar ergeben auch wer gar nicht
genau das kann ein grund sein deswegen
brauchen erbsen und bohnen auch
überhaupt keinen dünger also die sind ja
schwarz zähler anwachsen einfach auch
von gedüngten beten und das ist auch für
die veganer unter euch eine ziemlich
coole möglichkeit auf stickstoffdünger
wie müssten zu verzichten weil du ganz
einfach pflanzen anbauen kannst mit dem
du deine gemüse dienst in der
landwirtschaft wird es auch im schatten
carey system genannt da bauen die auf
ein feld geht zum beispiel an und das
wird geschnitten und dann auch die
fläche transportiert wo eben stickstoff
gebraucht wird und ja so kannst du im
prinzip auf tiere weitestgehend
verzichten hast du lust hast meine erste
in deinem garten angucken ja ja keine
ausnahme dann schauen wir mal ob maries
erbsen
also ich hoffe ihr seht das hier sind
kleine knubbel an genug sehen kann ja
mal ein auf knipsen
da haben wir einen kleinen kerl meint er
ist rot in maximal erklären warum der
rote das erbse und die gleichen
bakterien die müssen ganz schön aktiv
zusammenarbeiten damit diese symbiose
überhaupt so funktionieren kann die
kirchen bakterien bilden für die
stickstofffixierung das enzym nitrogen
nase und das ist extrem sauerstoff
empfindlich das problem ist aber dass
die kirchen bakterien sauerstoff
brauchen um überhaupt effizient arbeiten
zu können deswegen produziert die
pflanze das sogenannte qi mologen dass
es eisenhaltig und da
bildet in dem wurzel kirchen den
überschüssigen sauerstoff so dass der
sauerstoffgehalt balanciert ist und das
enzym lich kaputt geht und die kirchen
bakterien immer noch arbeiten können das
ist ziemlich cool
und wenn du deine erb so zum beispiel
ausgegraben hast und dann auch erkennt
das knöpfchen rotes dann weißt du dass
deine symbiose auch gerade aktiv ist
was noch wichtig ist zu wissen ist dass
knöllchen bakterien wird spezifisch sind
das heißt wenn du das erste mal
sojabohnen in deinem garten anbaut dann
wird wahrscheinlich nicht die gleichen
bakterien art schon in dem garten leben
die mit den sojabohnen eine symbiose
eingeht da kann man so wird es in der
landwirtschaft auch gemacht nachhelfen
und kann den boden mit den richtigen
riecher bakterien bekämpfen habe ich
noch nicht ausprobiert aber für die
leute von euch die lust haben das mal
auszuprobieren und gerade die die auch
keine knöllchen an ihren diagnosen
erkennen können ist das bestimmt ein
kohle methode um den boden so ein
bisschen wieder mit den stämmen
anzurufen und so hat es auch so eine
coole idee junge mahlzeit hast wenn man
jetzt keine knöllchen bakterien an den
rigorosen findet der nachbar aber
vielleicht welche hardy und einfach mal
hin zu gehen ein paar wurzel reste zu
klauen oder einfach die erde aus dem
beta ein bisschen was zu mopsen und das
weil sich zu hause vielleicht sogar in
der serie weil man erst aus zu bringen
wäre kann man vielleicht doch wenn ich
in den garten holen bin kleine da sind
ohne dass man was dazu kaufen muss das
auch eigenen tipp was man machen könnte
um die symbiose zwischen den leguminosen
und irgendwelchen bakterien zu fördern
ja es ist wichtig dass du darauf achtet
dass dein boden einen optimalen ph wert
hat der liegt meistens so zwischen 6 und
das kommt so ein bisschen darauf an auf
welchem boden du gärten hast ob es ein
sandiger boden ist oder ironiker boden
dann kannst du einfach mal ein ph-wert
teste deine moden durchführen und dann
bei bedarf kalten wenn du deinen boden
regelmäßig mit kompost für sorgst ihnen
blockhaft anstatt ihn zu wenden dann
tust du auch schon ganz viel für die
kirchen bakterien und sorgt dafür dass
sie eine symbiose mit deinen leguminosen
einnehmen können dann hast du auch noch
mehr tipps für die größeren
bodenlebewesen
man da machen kann zum beispiel für den
regenwurm ich glaube das interessiert
schon einige um den auch zu fernen im
garten also hier sind wir schon wieder
bei den gleichen methoden eigentlich
weil auch hier ist es wieder da wo ich
locker und richtig genau
ja du kannst du einen regenwurm am ab
und an mal ein paar nette ernte rechte
liegen lassen oder cafe carina
zimmermann ja auch richtig gerne ich
habe die erfahrung gemacht dass glaubt
blätter oder auch angelegte salatblätter
richtig gerne verputzt werden von den
regenwürmern ja worauf ich auch immer
achte ins dass ich die wurzeln immer im
boden lasse also wenn ich irgendwann
eine pflanze kompetent ferne dann
schneide ich dir nur über dem boden ab
weil gerade auch bei den kirchen
bakterien
da ist ja der ganze stickstoff dran und
wenn man sehen rausreißt dann hat man
eben nur ein bruchteil von dem mir
positiven effekt dann letztendlich in
seinem bett erhalten
aber auch bei den anderen pflanzen achte
ich darauf dass kommt so ein bisschen
natürlich auch darauf an wofür du die
leguminosen nutzen möchtest wenn du
jetzt wirklich als ziel heißt stickstoff
im boden anzureichern
dann würde ich auf jeden fall auch die
wurzeln im boden lassen denn erbsen
bohnen können zum beispiel ungefähr 200
kilo stickstoff pro hektar fixieren und
luzern oder klee sogar bis zu 400 kilo
stickstoff pro hektar und wenn man dann
mal vergleicht wie viel zum beispiel
kartoffeln vom an der gleichen fläche
entziehen
da kommen wir ungefähr so auf 200 kilo
auch pro hektar und ja das ist eine
ganze menge die man wieder in seinem
boden einbringen kann ohne dass man so
viel dafür gemacht heuer fragen ja auch
immer viele wie kann ich denn mein boden
denn ohne ständig dünger zu kaufen zu
müssen und das ist eine ganz tolle
methode wenn man dann auch noch die
reste kompostiert und den kommen fast
wieder im garten aus bringt ab und zu
mit ganzen jahre ansetzt und wenn man
hühner hat hat man von denen auch wieder
dünner und dann muss man eigentlich kaum
dünger zu kaufen also das klappt
eigentlich ganz gut aber zum beispiel
mit air wie nasse und so bin ich
manchmal auch ganz gut so eine kleine
kopftücher bei denen ganz einfach das
ist einfach auch schnell und ein
aber es geht auch einigermaßen im monat
davon also es lohnt sich auf jeden fall
mal genauer hinzuschauen sich die boden
tierchen anzuschauen wie mal zu
beobachten weil die wurzeln von euren
erbsen zu begutachten ob da alles gut
läuft oder ob man da vielleicht noch
nachhelfen könnte und ich fand es super
spannend hast du mal erzählt hanning
bodenlebewesen weil es ist so ein
wichtiges thema war cool dass du dabei
war ja er hat voll spaß gemacht danke
dann pflanzen mit post vor den dingen
kann
[Gelächter]